final fantasy 15 is almost upon us and a  day one update is adding a bit more to  the game at launch I'm Tony and this is  your patched GameSpot news update the  day one patch makes a handful of changes  but the most notable is the addition of  scenes from the King's glaive movie and  The Omen trailer into the game Square  Enix says this will make the story of  the FF 15 universe easier to follow for  newcomers the patch also adds more  in-game recipes and social options for  the character prompt OHS photos a few  smaller changes to menus and skill trees  are also included but these should all  generally improve the game Final Fantasy  15 hits ps4 and Xbox one on November  29th and the patch will be available the  same day word on Twitter says it clocks  in at 7.2 gigabytes but that number is  unconfirmed at this time in any case if  you want to keep up with all the latest  on Final Fantasy you're already in the  right place